sean mckenna is here with a gamespot  news update looks like the destiny beta  is coming this july according to today's  Activision Blizzard investor call we  already knew that the beta was launching  this summer and as a reminder it's  coming to PlayStation consoles first but  now we have a specific month to  anticipate the call also revealed that  Activision Blizzard's overall profits  this quarter are down thirty five  percent year-over-year but that isn't  stopping Activision from pouring five  hundred million dollars into development  and marketing for destiny the full game  is set to launch on sep tember ninth for  xbox 360 xbox one playstation 3 and  playstation 4 for more news on destiny  and the upcoming beta make sure to check  out gamespot com